yeah it's a girl
yeah it's like famous yeah they're
really famous yeah
what's up guys I'm Abella danger and I
am back to answer the internet would you
rather watch only sophomore important
for the rest of your life or only Minor
League Sports but I was at literally the
last World Series against the Astros and
the Braves yeah yeah oh my gosh I have
season tickets to heat but I just keep
watching the G League yeah no I can't I
can't I would rather have the softcore
porn because I could just make the
hardcore porn Messiah
[Laughter]
yeah what would you choose if you could
only have one for the rest of your life
well I'm not I don't have a dick so now
[ __ ] um regular sex or anal that is
[ __ ] hard because I [ __ ] love anal
and like I still love like it's like
very much a present thing in my life
it's not something that it's like I
abandoned it in a past like it's like
something that's like very much like
there and present very sexual you know
okay I guess I can still squirt with
regular sex so I'll keep regular sex and
just saying like I mean I gotta be able
to have one either squirting or but yeah
at least with regular sex I'll have like
vaginal orgasms even though I won't have
anal orgasms and I also get to squirt
but I can't Square for me you know so
that's the thing then I'll lose
squirting too would you rather never get
oral sex again or get only oral sex
again stop
with this question I'm fine never
getting oral sex again as long as I get
to give it but I'm definitely not just
gonna get only oral sex for the rest of
my life like a girl like you need the
insertion yeah
you need the but also like the force
like that like the
you need like the body weight unless
you're gonna be like laying on top of me
with doing like one of these like it's
just weird like I don't know how that
would I need yeah
would you rather be drunk 24 7 or never
be drunk again there's other things I
can do I guess but I don't think I could
function being drunk you're like six
years but when I'm drunk I'm like horny
and like I just want to eat and
yeah like I
I can't really retain information like
I'm gonna like you can't show up to
Debate Club drunk I know God I would
love to I hate my partner
oh my God I hope he doesn't watch this
but he really won't I don't want to
answer this it's like what's the
weirdest thing you've jerked off to and
even now in this climate it's not
anything illegal
okay would you rather always come
prematurely or never not at all
definitely always come prematurely and
the more often the better
um you know every 10 seconds as a guy
like if a guy comes prematurely you're
okay with it oh yeah yeah I never want a
guy to not come at all like I need that
it's gratification okay it's like not so
it's not long enough for you to get off
I don't care it's fine we can just go
again like it's fine give me a second
every time he's only good for a minute
it's fine I honestly still rather that
than a guy who like first of all never
comes at all or it takes a long time to
come like I still feel very much the
same I saw someone posted that video the
other day and said is this satire and
I'm like no I'm 100. I did someone
similar to this like would you rather a
guy lost last 50 seconds I remember when
you said short guys and the short Kings
United and [ __ ] himself sure Kings no
and now there's like a movement with
shark Kings you see I was ahead of that
I was ahead of that if you could make
any celebrity but you'd have to make a
sex tape with them that would go viral
would you do it
no I would not [ __ ] do it and I've
had guys and I've had celebrities like
want to film like sex with me and I'm
like are you [ __ ] insane like how are
you like I know I'm like a trusting
person but like how are you so trusting
that like I wouldn't put it out or
something like that which I would never
like I would never like disclose any of
my excavates but yeah like I've had guys
we even have like a dream person that
you would want to have like that
question is more like you would get to
bang your dream person yeah sex tape
because the sex tape part is easy for
you yeah I think yeah for sure like a
dream yeah it's a girl a girl yeah it's
like famous yeah they're really famous
yeah like Margot Robbie yeah
I don't think we have in common good
choice yeah really like Margot Robbie
yeah
would you die like if you met her have
you met her I mean I feel at this point
I wouldn't no we never met her put in a
good word
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out